today's society especially with social
media and instagram
you know it's great but oh my goodness
isn't it the cause of so much infidelity
people
control themselves
into a candy store and saying look at
all the sweeties honey but don't you
touch is that kid gonna touch hell yeah
that kid's gonna talk so would you
delete your instagram for a guy
uh yeah if i really read about him and
he was really
it's
unhappy
yeah
you would delete all your socials for
your guy yeah it's not my life
what about you what about you jessica if
you had a guy
no no
the hell do i look like doing anything
for a man i'm sorry but at the end of
the day
anyway pause wait wait i'm sorry we
don't have to pause because i was
literally talking
yeah you can't do you look like doing
anything for a man um
it's my life it's my social media if he
feels threatened by my social media
that's something that he has to unpack
himself no i'm not talking about i'm
talking about the statement that you
made what do i look like doing anything
for a man are you telling me that you
won't do anything for a man i'm it's a
joke bro breathe no i'm just asking the
question yes i would do something for a
man but it really depends on how much i
care about him and
how long we've you know
cultivated a true relationship with each
other in a true connection
but regardless
social media like it's not that serious
if something as small as social media
holds weight to you in a relationship
grow the [ __ ] up
like genuinely grow the [ __ ] up if
you're gonna sit there and be like
delete your instagram i can't handle
this unless i'm
out portraying a different way
unless i'm cheating and flirting because
i was not done talking
anyway
if you're going i could understand i
could understand
if i'm on there flirting and messing
around and cheating blatantly
absolutely you have every right to feel
that way but if i'm not doing anything
on my goddamn social media except for
posting a picture of me in front of a
bookstore or something mm-hmm relax what
if you're posting like sexy pictures
that men want to comment on and stuff
what the hell does that have to do with
me i'll block the guys
yeah but you don't think it's a little
bit you don't think it's a little bit
like attention seeking like because i
feel like you shouldn't post those traps
in a relationship do you agree or
disagree i don't know what the hell it's
like to post the thirst trap in a
relationship oh well i mean i used that
what i use what is that cause she's
never been in one in a relationship yeah
i've been in quite a few reasons she
just got out of a relationship i just
got out of one yeah no i'm just asking
i'm just talking um
but i've been in a relationship at least
where my partner kept on
getting booty hurt because of my
instagram because i was a micro
influencer at the time
and i don't i don't know what exactly
hurt him about it to this day
but there was like one bikini picture on
there and it wasn't like super raunchy
and sexy like it was just me by the pool
side
in a bikini like i feel like i should be
able to do that quickly period if i'm in
lingerie now that's a different story
yeah but you have to remember men are
territorial
naturally we are okay well we're not
animals so
you're not you're not gonna piss on me
to prove that you're i'm yours okay but
we are for example what does she look
like doing anything for a man so what if
he was posting like like
shirtless selfies like you wouldn't
that's totally up to him he's not gonna
i'm not going to be insecure over that i
know that my man is fine i just don't i
know that he's gonna get attention off
of it but it's up to me to trust him to
not entertain the [ __ ] in his dms
well i just think that's like a bad sign
like if i was in a relationship and the
guy was posting like shirtless selfies
and all this attention-seeking photos
i'd be like um i feel like i'm getting
cheated on that that's a matter of
boundaries that you would set in your
own relationship it's right
relationships it hasn't been a problem
aside from one time no no that's fine
and so you could say like you wouldn't
accept them
relationships
because i have an aggressive nature to
me that i think scares you a little bit
no i'm however which is good i'm just
analyzing it
um no i do not dominate the relationship
i make sure it's equal at all costs i
make sure that both of us always have an
opportunity to speak
say what's on our minds and set the
boundaries that are necessary and we
make compromises as necessary but i
definitely do not dominate and i make
sure my partner does not dominate either
because at the end of the day we are our
own individuals we can do what we please
as long as we're not upsetting each
other and doing things to intentionally
hurt each other
so you agree that you have an aggressive
nature
yeah
absolutely because
i'm very opinionated do you think that's
like dominating in a relationship no
because aggressive as you yes he was but
that's exactly what made it fun between
us and the times that i have dated men
yeah because we can both handle each
other just fine
most of the time when our relationships
end the ex you called didn't sound a
great was he really on the same level as
you because he really actually he didn't
he didn't sound like it no see but he
had grown a lot since then i don't know
him and i dated okay well i don't care
what you believe
so oh
[Music]
right so that was a totally different
chesca that we're dealing with right and
a totally different hymn that we're
dealing with you know back then you know
he was a serial cheater for sure like he
was walling out all the time and i think
i think he would have i'm going to be
honest when he was on the phone with you
i think he would have cheated again oh
he absolutely would have so
thank god huh did you no it was it was
she was on the show and it was like call
your ex and ask them on a date or
something and it was like he was like
kind of feeling the water
but he didn't he was but he didn't think
he he knew he he knew you weren't
serious
that question because remember the last
time on your show yeah and i said um
there are women that say oh yeah guys
cheat
and i said well women kind of cheat at
the same kind of rate that meant right
and i said does anyone hear cheat nope i
haven't cheated no i haven't so it's
like oh okay so women never really admit
are you saying are you saying that
everyone on the panel was lying listen
i'm just listen i can't i don't have a
lie detector test but i'm just saying
it's very interesting that women
call out men's cheating and not their
own do you know what i mean there is a
famous saying that the heart is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked what's that bible
verse yes it talks about how to preach
yeah so i think it's about sorry i think
it's about setting boundaries though
isn't it it's what you're both
comfortable with from the beginning
because i think this is where things can
get complicated and people can right
right and it's again double standards so
say for example you
you were liking something of someone and
your partner didn't like it but then
they were doing the same and they asked
you not to do it
and then but they continued on doing it
well that's double standards
i believe i honestly believe you should
never tell someone what to do you should
let a person make their own choice and
if you tell someone that it's kind of
made me a bit unhappy
i'm not i'm not too fond of that but if
i understand in context whilst you're
doing it and they say well this is this
that's out that's my friend or whatever
then fine but if they're then
deliberately continuously doing
something that you've said you know
makes you feel a bit uncomfortable then
it's acting out a malice isn't it yeah
do you know what i think it's so there
was a statement that i had read i'm
probably going to butcher it a little
bit but it was like you can tell someone
how to love you but it's up to them to
decide how to love you at the end of the
day yeah so based on their actions if
they truly love you they're going to do
what is necessary for you yeah at the
end of the day so yeah i guess knowing
each partner's love language exactly i
think sometimes that's the main thing
what happens in relationship what
relationships go sour is that because my
love language could be words of
affirmation but if i project that's my
partner's love language that's where
things can go wrong yeah and all of a
sudden i'm saying but i'm giving you
gifts because people have a tendency to
love others in their own love language
that's the problem women can change
their minds very easily what would you
say
take women's love languages simple we're
set in stone yeah men are more setting
stone than women
like so many girls on instagram i'm not
saying everyone but i'm saying some
people do i mean you're saying simple
but i don't think so because if it was
that simple would there'd be so much
choice on this so you realize
it's a small percentage of men that can
even do that
like
like um it's a very small percentage of
men that are even like sleeping with
anybody like that's the reason girls
hate men is because we're sleeping with
the same ones
no i'm like dead like because it's what
do they say if you ask 80 percent of
women what they like look for in a guy
they list 20 of them
and then the other the bottom 20 of
women like the 80 men are fighting over
basically